Fox's first primetime series married
with children remains notable for both
its risque jokes and abrupt cancellation
as well as delivering the fledgling Fox
Network of ratings hits have you
wondered what the members of the lovably
low class Bundy clan have been up to
since they went off the air here's what
they're working on now ed o'neill since
finding fame as curmudgeonly shoe
salesman al bundy ed o'neill has had a
pretty steady career that isn't to say
he hasn't suffered through a few dry
spells though o'neill starred in a
number of short-lived obscure projects
after married with children remember
John from Cincinnati Big Apple or the
2003 relaunch of dragnet we don't either
things turned around in 2009 when he
landed the role of Jay Pritchett on
ABC's award-winning Modern Family
aside from moving him into a higher tax
bracket in both his personal and
fictional lives
this also means O'Neal gets paid to
pretend Sofia Vergara is his wife a job
most guys would do for free a meal has
also found the time to earn a black belt
in Brazilian Jujitsu not bad for a guy
who recently turned 70 katey sagal after
ditching peg Bundy's giant red helmet of
hair Segal has worked pretty
consistently in addition to a
long-running gig as the voice of Leela
on Matt Groening animated Futurama Segal
starred in eight Simple Rules she then
went on to score a role on a little show
about a group of motorcycle enthusiasts
called Sons of Anarchy Segal's work as
the vicious anarchy matriarch Gemma
teller-morrow
was a far cry from her days as peg
instead of scarfing down bonbons she
proved she was just as good at kicking
butt and taking names of course the fact
that she's an are key creative wife
didn't hurt her chances of nabbing the
part but she definitely made the most of
the opportunity Segal took home a Golden
Globe and a prism award for the role and
she only had to kill a few people to get
there christina applegate as lovable
blonde bombshell Kelly Bundy Applegate
was a fan favorite but finding another
hit series hasn't been easy her first
starring sitcom role
NBC's Jesse lasted only two seasons and
her next TV project ABC's Samantha who
was canceled after two seasons as well
her third shot at post married sitcom
hit up all night was also off the air
after you guessed it two seasons she's
continued to work in film co-starring
and hits like the sweetest thing and the
anchorman movies but it hasn't improved
her television look all that
professional turmoil is nothing compared
to the personal battle she faced in 1998
when Applegate discovered she had breast
cancer luckily it was found in its early
stages and after a double mastectomy she
emerged cancer-free
David pastino Bud Bundy proved to be the
height of David Faustino's acting career
while he's worked consistently most of
his gigs have been one-off appearances
like his appearance in Entourage where
he plays himself on the other hand his
voice acting career has been more
prosperous
he's lent his vocal talents to popular
kid focused series like Winx Club and
The Legend of Korra you don't know
anything about me do you
yeah I'm brought a boy why is that how
do I not know stuff about you never
asked but the best thing about
Faustino's post married with children
life aside from shedding that glorious
mullet is his ability to stay out of
trouble
unlike many former child actors Faustino
hasn't amassed a collection of mug shots
he does have one arrest for marijuana
possession in 2007 according to Fox News
but other than that fusty knows been an
angel maybe some of that good karma will
pay off and his rumored married with
children spinoff series will be a hit
unlike previous spinoff attempts a man's
a purse if it seems like Amanda purse
who played Bundy neighbor Marcie Rhoades
Darcy disappeared from the TV it's
because she pretty much has since 2001
she's only appeared in front of the
camera only seven times however her
directing careers taken off she's lent
her camera talents to programs like
Dharma and Greg
madtv and the Rosie O'Donnell produced
the big gay sketch show off the set
first revealed some real-life animosity
between her and her television adversary
at O'Neal when she Wed Carrie shankin in
2010 O'Neal didn't get an invite because
first feared he'd laughed during the
ceremony after teasing her about her
chicken legs for over a decade what he
expects I am NOT a chicken Ted McGinley
known as much for his role on The Love
Boat as his work playing male bimbo
Jefferson Darcy Ted McGinley has worked
consistently since 1997 without landing
anything permanent I am great all right
his most prominent role came courtesy of
hope and faith which catapulted Kelly
Ripa's career and no one else's in fact
many consider McKinley's series presents
so lackluster that he's been accused of
carrying the McGinley curse which claims
that adding him to a show guarantees its
cancellation McKinley counters that
accusation by pointing out that many of
the shows he's appeared on lasted for
several seasons after he came aboard we
see your point McKinley but please don't
audition for Game of Thrones David
garrison since gaining fame as Steve
Rhodes David garrison has continued to
work in television from time to time
post married with children
Garrison's made dozens of one-off
appearances on shows like Arliss the
West Wing and The Good Wife
however his first love has always been
the theater to which he returned and
it's a good thing he did in addition to
appearing in Broadway productions of
bells are ringing and the visit garrison
was part of the original cast of the hit
wicked in which he played The Wizard of
Oz and a very weird off-broadway
Hannibal Lecter Michael the dog known to
most as Buck the Bundy's self-preserving
Briard Michael retired in 1995 as true
fans no buck was replaced by lucky the
cocker spaniel possessed by Bucks
reincarnated spirit sadly Michael
actually died less than a year after his
final appearance in 1996 so he didn't
get to enjoy a retirement for
very long michael was 92 in dog years
when he passed even though that's only
13 in human years it wouldn't be an
exaggeration to say he had a fuller life
than most of us ever will where exactly
am I
you're where animals go when they die
I'm in Oprah's refrigerator thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which TV show cast you'd
like to catch up with